would say you're two great Batmans on
screen are now the Nolan movies are my
favorites but I don't think Bale is the
best Batman I think that in fact I don't
I love bale as Wayne Bales I don't like
his Batman voice but I like those movies
I think your two best Batmans are
Keaton
and uh Affleck to me is the greatest
ever Batman really I think yeah are you
laughing at that I'm laughing yes
because he doesn't have enough I don't
feel like he established himself I think
he looks great as Batman right and I
think he's I think he's a good Batman
all right right
I like Robert Pattinson as Batman I I
hated that movie in ways I can't even
put into words you like a more Fiona
Apple Style Batman a week no no no eggs
under his eyes